في العراق اكدت هيئه الحشد الشعبي مقتل
احد قيادييها ابو باقر الساعدي بمسيره
استهدفت سيارته في بغداد وكانت مصادر
امنيه عراقيه قالت ان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا
بقصف نفذته مسيره واستهدف سياره مدنيه
رباعيه الدفع في منطقه المشتل شمال شرق
بغداد اضاف مراسلنا ان قوات الامن اغلقت
جميع الطرق المؤديه الى المنطقه الخضراء
التي تضم المقار الح الحكوميه
والدبلوماسيه ومنها السفاره
الامريكيه وكانت وسائل الاعلام المقربه من
الفصائل العراقيه قالت ان من بين القتلى
قياديين في حزب الله العراقي هما ابو باقر
الساعدي واركان العلياوي بينما قالت وسائل
اعلام المقربه من الفصائل المسلحه ان
هجوما ثانيا وقع في منطقه جميله شرقيه
بغداد وقد اعلنت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
قتل من وصفته بقائد كبير في كتائب حزب
الله العراقي عبر غاره على بغداد اضافت
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه في بيان ان
الغاره ادت الى مقتل مسؤول عن التخطيط
المباشر والمشاركه في الهجمات على القوات
الامريكيه في المنطقه وان العمليه رد على
الهجمات التي تستهدف الجنود
الامريكيين من جانبها اعلنت حركه الجباء
في العراق ان الرد على القصف الذي استهدف
القيادي ابو بقر الساعدي سيكون مركزا ولن
يمر الامر دون عقاب من جانبه قال الامين
العام لعصائب باهل الحق ان على العراق
تقديم طلب الرسمي لمجلس الامن للمطالبه
بانسحاب فوري للقوات الاجنبيه اضاف ان
الاعتداءات الامريكيه لم تتوقف رغم خطوره
بل رغم خطوات الحكومه العراقيه والتزام
الفصائل
التهدئه ينضم الينا من مونتانا مايكل نائب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق للشرق
الاوسط ضيفنا تنتقل الولايات المتحده اذا
بذلك من قصف لمقرات في المناطق الحدوديه
سواء في العراق وسوريا الى قلب بغداد
واغتيالات ما مستوى التصعيد برايك
هذا يسعدني اكون معكم اولا اعتقد ان هذا
الامر يظهر ان الولايات المتحده عازمه على
محاسبه الذين كانوا مسؤولين عن الهجوم على
البرج 22 وقتل ثلاثه عسكريين طبعا انا لا
اعتقد ان هذا تصعيد بل اراه رده فعل على
هجوم ل على الولايات المتحده الولايات
المتحده عليها مسؤوليه الدفاع عن حياه
النساء والرجال من الافراد في القوات
المسلحه كما حصل في العراق وسوريا اعتقد
ان هذا سيسبب مشكلات للحكومه العراقيه هذا
امر مؤسف لان الشراكه بين الولايات
المتحده والعراق مهم ان تبقى لكن اعتقد ان
هذا كان ردا وردا
ان انتقام
على ما قامت بكتائب حزب الله لكن ال
المتحده لا يمكن ان تقف موقف المتفرج
سيسبب مشكله للحكومه العراقيه
داخليا وخارجيا كيف تتعامل الولايات
المتحده اذا مع حليفتها كما قلت الحكومه
العراقيه في ازاء هذا التطور في
العمليات
سيكون من الافضل للجميع لو ان الحكومه
العراقيه تجد طريقه لايقاف الهجمات على
قواعدها لان هذه القواعد العراقيه التي
تؤوي الافراد الامريكيين طبعا الامر ليس
كذلك هذه الفصائل تفعل ما تشاء لهذا السبب
الشراكه العراقيه الامريكيه مهمه والتي اد
الى الحاق الهزيمه بداعش لكن هناك مشكلات
والمفاوضات والمحادثات التي تدور حول
انسحاب الولايات المتحده وبوقت اسرع للاسف
اذا تم ذلك هذا قد يؤثر في المحادثات لكن
لا يمكن الولايات المتحده ان تقف مكتوفه
الايدي ازاء هجمات تتعرض
لها